we've already looked at um finding the
greatest coefficient
right and we um if you remember the
whole idea was that
when you take the
coefficient to get out a pascal's
triangle right if they're
unmodified you have something like say
one plus x
to the power of four right the greatest
coefficient is going to be right in the
middle
but as soon as you start to change these
numbers right it starts to skew
you know where the top will be it'll be
over this way or this way depending on
which numbers
greater and how much greater it is right
so it's just
about finding the biggest one and you
remember that i think the condition we
used was
when does the coefficient of one become
greater than the coefficient of the next
one
and then we have all this factorial and
ncr notation it all canceled out right
okay so kind of an extension of that or
a more general way of
um tackling the same kind of question is
what if you want a coefficient of
some specific term i don't know whether
it's the greatest double b or whatever
how do we work it out well here we have
these kinds of shortcuts right to get us
straight to the correct term
this time we're not so lucky so we're
going to have to do some kind of
expansion at least
maybe not all 13 turns but we'll have to
do so
okay so let's start by writing out two x
cubed morning come on in
um what are the first few terms of the
expansion and you'll notice
one of the things that's tricky about it
is that you've got the x cubed and
you've got the one over x so
not only are the constants interacting
each other with each other
but the x terms are also canceling out
and adding together and so on
all right first term um remember every
term has got its three components
it has its binomial coefficient then it
has some of the first term and sum of
the
last term right so what's the binomial
coefficient of the very first term
in this case
12 twelve because that's the row of
pascal's triangle i'm in
do not choose zero not that's the zero
term if you like okay uh and that's why
it's one
there's the binomial coefficient then
i'm gonna have some number of these guys
right 2 x cubed how many will i have
this is the first term right so i'm just
going to have 12
and just for the sake of completeness
i'm going to have a notice there's a
minus right
so a minus 1 over x i'm going to have
zero lots of him
okay right now i'm doing it all even
though this is trivial and this is
trivial so that when i go from term to
term i'll know how they progress
okay so the next one obviously will just
be 12 choose one
right i'm going to have one less lot of
the 2x cubed
so i'll have 11 lots of here and then
i'll have one lot of the
minus one and x right
okay i think i can probably do one more
and then i can start to generalize
there right the next one will be 12
choose two
there will be this many lots of that and
that many lots okay now i know the
series doesn't go on forever
but um it goes on enough that i'm
already getting the pattern that i'm
after okay
now i'm after the coefficient of x to
the eight right so i need to know well
which term does that come up in
okay so i've written out this many terms
so i can see
what the coefficient sorry what the
index will be and then i can work out
where
x to the 8 appears okay so the first
index here is 3
times 12 and there's no lots of this
right so it'll be
some coefficient times x to the 36
right i don't know what this coefficient
will be that's part of the question
the next one will have another
coefficient but what will its power be
this will be 33 right and then it's
going to be
-1 so its coefficient will be
32 right
okay let's just verify what's happening
to the next one this is 30
minus two lots right so 28.
so some other coefficient x to the 28
and so on okay so
this term has 36 this term has 32 this
term is 28 so it's going down it's an ap
okay which term will have x to the 8 in
it
count it down 36
32 28 24
20 16 16
12 8. so to get down to x to the eight
i've got a good
forward to the eighth term okay so
that will appear in the eighth
okay so now that i know which term it is
now i just have to work out what the
coefficient is okay and thankfully i've
already written out what the pattern for
each of the coefficients is
each of the terms is so therefore i can
work out the coefficient
that will be
well okay let's see here what will be my
binomial coefficient at the front
don't forget it starts at zero right so
the eighth term along will be
12 choose seven okay
now that seven and these numbers here
right how do they relate to each other
i'm going to have 7 less than
12 right because that's counting down
right
and then how many lots of this am i
going to get
7 okay now actually because it's the
coefficient
right i can actually leave off every
part of it that has an x in it okay
so i can probably just say don't worry
about that x
cubed okay and don't worry about that x
what i'm interested in is the two and
the minus one that's what's going to
give you the coefficient
okay so then
uh 1237 i don't know what 127 is
that's a big number 2 to the 5 is 32
don't forget the negative side since
there's an odd number of them i am going
to get a minus 1
on the end and that's going to give me
minus 25 344
okay yeah all right
now i'm going to get you to practice on
a separate one
write it down
say it again
well okay so i'm not asking for greatest
right i'm just asking for a specific
coefficient
so be positive or negative because
there's just the one negative here every
alternate one will be negative
and this one happens to be negative so
you just leave it as negative
okay all right